malgré le vent et la pluie 35000
personnes policiers en soutien syndicats
et politiques de tous bords ont convergé
devant l'assemblée nationale sur le quai
d'orsay
les policiers réclament davantage de
moyens humains et financiers une
meilleure protection
une simplification de la procédure
pénale et des peines plancher en
tribunes ils ont dénoncé le police
bashing l'impunité grandissante la
spirale de la violence
ils ont également rendu hommage au
policier décédé on écoute des
responsables syndicalistes site on
constate qu il ya beaucoup de forces de
sécurité intérieure de policiers mais
aussi de citoyens qui sont de nombreux
soutenir leurs polices et sator un peu
le cou à la thèse qu'accréditent le fait
que la population ne nous soutient pas
et bien c'est tout l'averse pourquoi la
douceur pour l'instant très satisfait et
si nous sommes rassemblés ici c'est
surtout pour nous deux pour dénoncer les
conditions de travail insupportables
avec le travail on est surtout mis les
violences les violences dont nous sommes
les cibles quotidiennement c'est pour ça
que nous nous voulons des actes il ya
tous les élus qui sont là qui se font
une tribune politique qui sont venus au
moins je demande à tous ses élus au delà
de leurs clivages politiques d'aller
dans l'autre sens pour faire en sorte
que les réponses pénales soit très ferme
immédiate lorsque les policiers sont
attaqués on verra pour la suite du
mouvement en tout cas une chose est sûre
c'est que ça peut durer très longtemps
et on lâchera pas son coach il y aura en
effet le premier ministre nous a reçus
et nous a reçus nous a pas annoncé grand
chose en tout cas rien de suffisant pour
nous tant qu'il n'y aura pas ces peines
minimales qu'on arrête de nous trouver
des excuses sur la constitution et
autres si c'est anticonstitutionnel
varrault voyons la constitution s'il
faut légiférer y avait beaucoup d'élus
c'est leur rôle de travail à l'assemblée
pour faire en sorte que les policiers
soient respectées et considérées
mais une bonne fois pour toutes pensons
aux collègues sur le terrain qui climat
longueur de temps qui sont régulièrement
blessé qui sont tués pense aux familles
des victimes et pensons aussi aux
citoyens ils étaient là aujourd'hui le
citoyen en a marre de ces nuisances et
incivilités cette violence et
dangerosité tout le monde en a marre
donc le gouvernement doit prendre
conscience de la situation parce que
nous on va continuer on va pas lâcher
des élus de tous bords étaient venus
nombreux mais ils n'ont bien sûr pas eu
le droit de s'exprimer à la tribune des
syndicalistes on écoute olivier faure
pour le ps et jordan bardella pour le rn
moi je suis venu
j'ai un dialogue avec eux sur les
meilleures réponses à apporter aux
problèmes qu'ils posent le problème
qu'il pose c'est effectivement des gens
qui sont insuffisamment condamner des
gens qui sont parfois relâchés sans
avoir eu à subir la moindre sanction est
donc comment est-ce qu'on répond à ces
événements à ces faits qui ont été
rappelés dans l'après-midi et qu'elle
s'attende à travers sa tante d'exemple
nous avons commencé à dialoguer avec eux
lundi dernier lors d'une intersyndicale
avec laquelle nous avons dialogué
nous allons continuer semaine après
semaine pour chercher à apporter les
solutions qui permettront à chacune et à
chacun d'aller vers ce but commun qui
est la protection des français
moi j'ai entendu les syndicats appelé
l'intégralité des formations politiques
et des citoyens à venir se joindre à eux
c'est ce que nous faisons à la fois pour
leur témoigner la reconnaissance de la
nation est évidemment celle du
rassemblement national beaucoup le
rétablissement des peines planchers le
mandat de dépôt systématique lorsque
vous touchez aujourd'hui à un policier
qui est une exception ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui les forces de l'ordre ce
qu'elles sont agressés recroise bien
souvent leur agresseur dans les semaines
qui suivent la volonté de les protéger
aujourd'hui par le droit en instaurant
une présomption de légitime défense
beaucoup de mesures que nous avons
longtemps porté dans le débat public et
qui sont aujourd'hui portés c'est vrai
par les forces de l'ordre et que nous
mettre en oeuvre à la tête de l'état la
polémique c'est bien sûr la venue du
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
qui est aussi le premier flic de france
en tribune on a pu entendre le problème
de la police et la justice
le nom du garde des sceaux avec dupond
moretti s'est fait huer certaines
organisations de policiers dénonce une
récupération politique
mais maintenant ils attendent des actes